quels risques la russie fait elle courir
à l'europe et au monde volodymyr
zelensky met en garde contre une
catastrophe en cas d'incident
radioactifs asa porridge à la centrale
nucléaire la plus grande d'europe se
retrouve à nouveau au coeur des combats
après s'être entretenu au téléphone avec
le président ukrainien emmanuel macron
appelle au retrait des forces russes des
abords du site bruno daroux la sécurité
de la centrale inquiète les européens
oui et ce n'est pas de ce n'est pas
d'aujourd'hui il ya déjà eu les pays du
g7 les pays européens qui ont demandé à
ce que les troupes russes se retire de
la centrale nucléaire de zaporijia le
secrétaire général de l'onu monsieur
goûter rsa fait la même demande sans
pour le moment faire beaucoup bougé la
position de vladimir poutine il est donc
peu probable que cette demande d'
emmanuel macron obtiennent à un avis
favorable en quelque sorte de la part du
président russe dont cette demande elle
est toujours là mais en attendant les
troupes russes restent massés autour de
la centrale après le deuxième aspect
concernant ce site c'est
faut-il poteau envoyer une mission de
laguiole agence internationale pour
l'énergie atomique sur place alors
emmanuel macron fait savoir par son
entourage que les deux chefs d'état
lui-même et monsieur zemsky ou parler
des modalités d'une telle mission ce qui
semblerait indiquer rappelle une
certaine évolution de l'ukraine qui
jusqu'à présent ils étaient opposés
alors il ne s'agit pas encore d'un avis
positif de la part de kiev mais on sent
que ça bouge un peu jusqu'à présent qui
a fêté opposé à cette mission de lier
tout simplement parce qu elle estimé que
ça reviendrait à reconnaître en quelque
sorte la souveraineté de la russie sur
ce terrain de zappos région